hello I'd like to talk about almond milk
today honey let's let me just do my
thing okay hi guys hi we are back with
another video on the our favorite keto
products yes and so what was that yeah I
just want to make sure we have one mic
so we're sharing it today I think you
should just I'll leave it on yeah I'll
do all the talking okay so the first
product is almond milk this is a really
great product it's called
Ellie's best bigger better nut milk bag
easy to make it all by yourself
we're going to take these almonds high
quality almonds and then we're gonna
turn into almond milk and what do you
use almond milk for well I mean you just
drink it you can drink it with your keto
cookies I say that again no okay okay
you drink you with anything your keto
cookies we are gonna also be going over
an amazing granola that we have you
drink it instead of milk you can put it
in your tea or coffee anything your
shakes exactly I'm glad that you
clarified that because people just don't
know why to drink this stuff almond milk
you know actual regular milk is becoming
a big problem so this is a non dairy
products oh the first thing we're gonna
do guys you're going to taste take a cup
of almonds and we're gonna soak it in
water overnight and what that does is it
germinates it so while Karen's rinsing
this out go ahead and rinse that out
Karen I'm gonna talk about what
germinating is which you're soaking your
nuts I'm sorry you guys so so Cleese
things overnight you're getting rid of
enzyme inhibitors so those are the
things that block enzymes so now we can
actually digest those things so it
doesn't below you and I think one of the
big problems is that for the gall
bladder if you're consuming nuts with
enzyme inhibitors you're gonna create a
lot of gall bladder congestion so you're
really making a lot of noise over there
Karen but that's fine
so we rinsed them out and now what we're
gonna do is we're gonna blend them
with water a blender four to four and a
half cups of water for these nuts
okay very good
keep in mind when you're soaked in the
nuts overnight they do swell so make
sure your container has enough room this
is a little over four cups of water it's
interesting because I didn't know you
had to dilute it that much but you do
and then we're gonna add some so we're
gonna even illah a half a teaspoon of
vanilla and this is in this container
because I make made my own vanilla last
year in your spare time you know all my
free time a little heavy okay okay and
then a half a teaspoon of salt now this
is Himalayan salt Himalayan salt the
best yeah you can add a sweetener if you
want to we don't drink our beverage is
sweet almond milk coconut milk tea
coffee so we're not gonna sweeten it but
you could put some stevia or something
like that in there okay now we're gonna
make a lot of noise ready
[Applause]
well that was a long long ggest minute
in the world long time when you're just
watching it okay now what do we do okay
so now what we're gonna do is we're
gonna pour it in this nifty bag here
awesome bag over a large ball we're
basically gonna strain the mixture and
we're gonna squeeze we're gonna squeeze
it all out until the mixture inside is
pretty dry so here we go it actually
makes quite a bit of milk for just a
small amount of almonds one cup this is
like one cup of almonds this making all
this milk this is awesome okay so now
now you tight you can actually tighten
the strings okay but you're still gonna
have to squeeze the bag even if you
tighten the strings right so you're
gonna squeeze and twist I'm just gonna
get all the liquid out of it
it's a lot of good milk there and you
know what's cool about this is you know
when you buy in the store it comes with
carrageen which a lot of people don't
like that ingredient is it's kind of
questionable but this has just basically
almonds salt vanilla and water that's it
and these are some high-quality wild
harvested raw sweet almonds family
farmed and they're natural which is even
better so you know cuz the problem is if
you consume these nuts just by itself
they have enzyme inhibitors so it's hard
to digest you have to either bury your
nuts in the backyard and then germinate
them or soak them overnight baby and
soak your nuts
[Music]
all right good okay maybe we'll do
another video on all your impressions
Karen that's for another day another day
so I don't I don't want to kwikki this
but it does say keep going until the
almond mixture is really dry so you've
squeezed out all the liquid and we're
getting there that's good I guess you
could be perfect in all of this for the
demonstration we're gonna end right
there I think thank you good okay all
right now what we have is we have our
milk yes
why don't we pour some in the air and
test it out pour some in there and then
okay great bring our back the pitcher
back now it does say chill immediately
before you serve so we're not
necessarily gonna do that no because we
want to show how it is to enjoy it right
that's correct
Kevin all right okay actually it's
pretty good I read already tried it
before but let's just pretend like we've
never tried this back Hey hmm mmm that
is good is wonderful and I think ice
cold really good yeah amazing mm-hmm
awesome okay good now let's go to the
granola all right we're gonna try our
next thing okay so now we're gonna do
some granola okay Wow
that's right this is a punch to the
palate - the sugar and the violence it's
really cool this company makes granola
it's Tony keto friendly there's flavors
a salted caramel brownie snickerdoodle
cookie and that's another salted caramel
they have different flavors and probably
other flavors but my kids ate them all
yeah we had a problem with that we have
to hide this because my adult children
they like to eat granola yet this is
about the keto Baking Company I actually
interviewed her so she basically does
all this in a kitchen it's a community
kitchen so it's a lot of work and let's
go ahead and sample it Karen okay while
you while we're pouring that and I want
to tell you the ingredients so first of
all it's extra virgin coconut oil no
coconut a wreath rotol which is a really
good sweetener almonds flax seed walnuts
pecans unsweetened cocoa chips
free-range eye
so that eggs cocoa powder Himalayan pink
sea salt grass-fed bovine collagen
stevia natural flavours sodium
bicarbonate which is baking soda okay
what all those make sure you have this
here so they can see so all of these
ingredients together make a really
really yummy cereal and granola you
could munch it down out of a bowl like I
have or have it with milk let's do it
let's try it so not too much chewing you
have the mic it's good it's really good
you know and it's just nice I'm not a
big bread person but it is nice to sit
with a bowl of cereal I don't know if
it's just in my head that that's
comforting or wonderful but what's just
in your head yeah it's a great it's a
great experience this could be used as a
dessert or possibly a meal you have to
add some other things now when we try to
make our home granola at one time we're
looking at having some granola I'm a
racer NOLA it was amazing yeah huge
demands for migrants a big project but
what was the flaw it's really hard to
make it without oats mm-hmm
so this is a winner guys this is a
really good product we like this is
another favorite product so now let's go
to the next product okay all right so we
got the next product this is called
goodies goodies sugar-free sweetness so
if pancakes brownies cookies that's
right and you know what I like about
this camp what no maltitol uh mommy
likey and you know why no multi tall my
tummy knows why
yeah and has a glycemic index of like 53
that's like almost like sugar it's the
worst why sugar as a sugar substitute it
and all the sugar-free stuff but if it
still jacks your blood sugar slide
sugars um you know that's if I knew that
would I be standing here right now
probably not but anyway this is good
almond flour it's great ingredients so
we're gonna try these so we're not
trying this we're not gonna be trying
the pancake we're gonna be trying the
cookies why is that because we made all
the other ingredients when we already
made the other packages and I just
didn't as you say get around to it well
the problem is keeping those in the
house right right it was all we could do
to have enough cookies to sample because
our kids ate them all I had to hide them
in a utility drawer seriously and then
my daughter-in-law found them getting
some batteries she's like oh these
cookies okay well I'm glad you saved at
least two so we could sample their sugar
cookies yeah mm-hmm great yeah so for
those people that need convenience is
that pancakes cookies and brownies so
there's a lot of people that like
brownies mm-hmm you're eating faster
than me so I'm sorry
that's okay mm-hmm convenience it's good
so remember guys this is your dessert
it's not the meal this is not the snack
something in your throat it's for it's
meant to be like I better not put that
back after the meal snack police will
that's right okay look I like to make
stuff from scratch but there are times I
don't have the time for that I don't
have the ingredients all you need is a
pack of this and there's two other
ingredients that's all that we added to
these and I say we I mean me it was so
simple it was so fast
and goodies that's good news that's
right awesome so let's show you let's
let's go to the next one
okay okay we're at the next product okay
cauliflower crust okay so this comes in
three different flavors we've got sweet
red pepper we got the original Italian
and then we have the spicy jalapeno oh
that sounds great now you know first of
all I like that they call cauliflower
the new white flower because people are
using cauliflower in so many ways and I
dig it
I love cauliflower it's my all-time
favorite vegetable now and there's so
many things that you can do with
cauliflower it's off the charts and you
just have to google and experiment
you'll love it
and it's true maybe you know we have our
cauliflower pizza made from scratch and
that's awesome just like anything made
from scratch at home is wonderful but
let's face it dr. Berg sometimes you
don't have time to do that or you don't
want to do it are you seeing some people
like convenience are you trying to say
that Lee they just want to go to their
fridge they want to go to their freezer
and they want to be able to pull out
that crust and then still they're custom
making it however they want to I dig
that idea and I'm really glad these guys
came up with it with the keto frame of
mine well I think we should just want to
make sure the biggest concern that most
people have is it gluten-free let me
just tell you the ingredients guys it
has fresh cauliflower mozzarella cheese
egg whites jalapeno garlic and chili
flakes that's it and look how cute Amy
is she's on she's on every box and she
issues
Dora ball right so with all of that how
can it possibly be bad so let's free
let's eat this let's eat it can let's
see what happens beneath you know I
didn't add my red pepper chili peppers
was it for garlic which I always have to
have that in the crust mm-hmm Wow
she got she got that right mm-hmm mm-hmm
yeah did you bring the napkins No
you know look em mmm this is good mm-hmm
you guys are gonna enjoy this make your
homemade when you want to but have this
in your freezer this means I need to
sound pitchy but this crust is Italian
oh the Italian it's sweet that's a nice
little flavor mm-hmm she got that right
mm-hmm mm-hmm
okay that that's the thumbs-up right yep
this is awesome good let's go to the
next one we're gonna do another one all
right we're at the next and last product
review this is called cocoa perfection
this is the probably the most ultimate
very low very low carb if any it's like
zero sugar type product on sharpen yeah
it's awesome yeah it's very high quality
so there's a couple flavors this is a
whole bar and it is almond dark
chocolate so if I open the bar you can
see that it is a chocolate bar and you
can see the almonds look how beautiful
that is
okay I don't think we're just simply
gorgeous do you want to bite yep okay
that one's for you
these are big bites this is really
amazing mm-hmm it's still high-quality
mm-hmm it doesn't have that flat waxy
tastes um I don't know it just seems
like sugar alternative chocolates have
all that same kind of flat not full rich
chocolate taste but this has that
amazing chocolate flavor it's a candy
bar so we could basically do this as a
snack right I'm gonna let you answer
that that's it you know I feel like you
set me up with that question is
basically after the meal as your dessert
and let me just tell you something
Karen the first ingredient is dry cocoa
solids roasted almonds chicory root
fiber arethe rotol coconut butter and
vanilla extract I mean that's it so
a lot of times when you get these
sugar-free bars it comes with maltitol
and different sweeteners that give a lot
of digestive issues oh and I can tell
you I'm really sensitive to that and I
did I'm sure you'd be shocked to know
that I sampled these yesterday
I am shocked I can't zero-zero effect it
was a beautiful thing I mean I've tried
these over the over the years and I keep
coming back like this is like the top
top one so if you want quality if you
want something good this is it right and
this flavor is chocolate mint no I don't
know I remember growing up and going out
to dinner to a steak house with my whole
family and at the end of the meal you
would get those little like I think that
our Andes candies or something they're
little chocolates and they're minty and
I just hoarded everybody's joint your
minute you want your mint
you know this reminds me of that this is
a little mint wafer chocolate wafer it
is so lovely it is exactly that it's
it's awesome look how little it is so
they have the mint chocolate dark
chocolate we have the orange dark
chocolate orange chocolate and then the
other one is just a dark chocolate a
regular chocolate yeah it's pretty good
I mean there's there's people out there
that like chocolate I know that's hard
to believe they there and they want to
know if they can have chocolate yeah as
long as this is low sugar this has a net
carb of - so we're monitoring the fiber
and two carbs not bad mm-hmm not bad so
yeah if you're gonna do chocolate this
is something you may want to try out
have a little chocolate for a nice
dinner or around the holiday if you ever
put candy out this is the perfect
alternative there you have it that's a
review of our favorite keto products
right enjoy them
good good good
probably got me probably doesn't matter
but all this step on the cake please
don't say a couple chains I'm good with
that